like lots of people I'm stuck at home
self quarantine
to stop the spread of the novel
coronavirus and since I can't get into a
studio I figured I'd do an experiment
here at home this powder is a common
teaching aid that sticks to your skin
and other surfaces and it glows under UV
light you've probably seen it in a lot
of other videos it'll demonstrate what
we normally can't see the movement of
viruses like this one
the corona virus has a highly effective
technique for jumping from person to
person surfaces you name it but it's
also vulnerable to some pretty basic
cleaning regimens
so let's see how easily it spreads and
what you can do about it the process
that spreads the corona virus starts in
the lungs and the throat so they sort of
fooled us all and then yourself missed a
case something useful and then they'll
basically hijack yourself for the
purpose of the spread of the virus hong
jiao is a microbiologist at UCLA he says
basically the corona virus enters a cell
and multiplies sometimes millions of
times all of those copies then spill out
into patient's Airways and some of those
copies end up in tiny droplets of fluid
then when the patient coughs or sneezes
those droplets spray out onto tabletops
and railings bus seats food other people
you name it and each droplet can carry a
heavy load so you can do this
calculation you can see that you could
easily fit you know thousands of virus
particle each droplet of course and you
only do what you only need a virus to
infect you one really big way to break
the chain of transmission is
hand-washing let's say I've been out
went about all day and I haven't been
really careful about where my hands have
been I get home I put my stuff away I
pet the dog I relax but you know what
else I do a lot I touch my face you seem
to affect you ourselves either through
your you know your mouth and through
your eyes your nose so that's why it's
so important you don't touch your face
so you should try touching your face
less but washing your hands makes those
slip-ups less dangerous you've heard the
recommendation before 20 seconds of
thorough scrubbing
so because soap it turns out is a pretty
magical substance
it contains detergent molecules that
surround and pull apart fats or lipids
and lipids are partly what coronavirus
membranes are made of
so when detergent molecules meet a virus
they force its membrane open tearing it
apart and rendering it inactive experts
also recommend cleaning frequently used
surfaces early studies show that
coronavirus can live on surfaces for
days so remember my getting home routine
everything from my light switches to my
door to my keyboard by game controllers
even my dog glowed under the UV light
luckily plenty of bleaches and other
household cleaners also destroy the
virus particles in their own way just
don't use those cleaners on your dog the
EPA has a list of cleaners that will
help and we've got them linked in the
description below to be clear
researchers still have a lot to learn
about this virus but what we just
demonstrated our best practices for lots
of diseases so keep up to date on the
news because we're going to be learning
more and more each day
lastly follow the guidance that applies
to you for social distancing it's how we
got into this situation in the first
place all these things started with a
single virus in the entire world okay so
we need to stop the we need to cut the
chain of spreading so small things we do
can help a lot